he's got milky tits over them okay so
i'll let me get into it then ethan kline
give him a round of applause thank you
so i'm gonna tell you something
and i'll tell you the problem i knew
this was gonna be a showdown because
there's no showdown
i'm not a gotcha podcast
it's a showdown and i'll and i'll tell
you how i knew
is because
bobby did our show recently and it was a
lot of fun by the way you came when
oliver tree was there when we boxed and
it was so much fun having you there
everybody loved seeing you it was
fantastic my our fans love you bobby and
i love you too
that all being said that all being said
when you were visiting i saw what i
thought i thought
you know was an alarming
shaped and sized mole
okay
now as a friend as someone who cares
about you as someone who could have
potentially saved your life
i felt it was my duty to say something
to you and not only that i showed it to
abe now i didn't show to a doctor you
misre represented that a little bit when
you were ranting about me
i said i showed it to a b now who the
[ __ ] is abe he works on our show i love
him he's great and he's pr he was in
pre-med
also he showed it to
a doctor and his family and they all
said he should get it checked out so
even so i i cross checked it with a few
people and then when i was like okay so
i should really push this and i texted i
said bobby you're gonna [ __ ] die i
was i sent the text message they're like
yo that's cancerous because i wanted to
scare you because i really wanted you to
go see the dermatologist
and you did okay can i and and and by
the way when i told this story
may i you said my name
i know but you said it too early you
said it too early but go ahead but i
just want to say my piece and then you
can go cause this is a hit piece i knew
this would be
it's not a hit piece
i don't know what that means i'm not
that kind of a guy you know what i mean
wait me normally if without the [ __ ]
most incident i'd be like ethan klein's
coming over we hippy hooray
but so and when i told this story on my
show
everyone said you know what even though
it was a a minor inconvenience to bobby
we and you love him so much it's
important that you say something because
you never know you always hear these
stories about like there's people on the
tv they've got a lump on their neck or
something and then someone writes them
an email and they go to doctor check it
out saves their life same thing with you
know uh moles and stuff thank you you're
welcome thanks for saying thank you what
a good friend but you got it removed
right
yeah thank you what a good friend why'd
you remove it
to prove you're wrong
how does that prove me wrong may i tell
my side no and did they get a biopsy i
tell my side now
can i tell my side did they biopsy it
yeah and did we get the results back
yeah not yet
they did you did yeah
nothing nothing okay good may it's not
good
okay good i may say mine yes okay so
you know um
if i had a friend
who had a mole
that looked first of all it's none of my
business
number one is i don't know what they're
doing creatively with their body uh you
know what i'm saying what people do
creatively with their body is none of my
business creatively
whatever they if they want to grow a
skin tag or whatever they want to do you
know
okay let me finish i got to talk you i
didn't interrupt you but i didn't
interrupt you okay all right you'll be
rude
okay i'm sorry all right
please right you have unresolved
problems with me though it seems like
that's why i'm getting it not now man
but it's like i can't okay
what's your problem why can't why can't
you just listen
i've listened to everything you said you
know you're right you said you said
you're freestyling with your body what
am i how am i supposed to all right all
right so i'm saying if i saw a maul i
would say it one time i just look at a
guy dude you'll bro that mole looks i
like it but it cool art but um get it
checked out right i would let it go at
that that's not what you did though
mm-hmm during that day you probably said
it eight to ten times no on your
yourself
yeah you kept going yeah man you should
go to get that check that's a real
concern
let me just say something okay let me
finish that's what i write but it wasn't
eight and am
okay what number do you think it is are
you talking about when i when you were
there in person yes i definitely said it
to you a few times okay and i followed
up in text messages all right so you did
that yeah and then i would say it one
time anyway yeah um
and then
literally i got in my car you you
literally went you should really get
that checked out
like it's it's cancer like you said it
was cancer
no i can read it right now yeah you can
read it okay
i didn't say it's cancer how would i
know that right so i just said it could
be i i i'll hear let me pull up my phone
too so yeah yeah so um
you can see
let me pull this up here's where's bobby
all right so let me pull this out i had
to pay the price of eating the scabs
dude what though you didn't eat the
stuff i could show you the scab
i got it right here all right
yeah go ahead i first i sent you an
image of
okay here we go okay wait here here you
want to read you said you want me to
read it i'll read it first yeah all
right you go see a dermatologist is that
what you're starting no st you can start
with the nice message that i sent you
first i don't want to i said thank you
bro was so nice seeing you you added so
much to the show today it was fun love
hanging out then you say all right so
all right all right so all right let's
used to ask me let me okay let me go
right you go thank you bro it was nice
seeing you you added a lot to the show
today right and i said
it was fun love hanging out it should
have ended there okay but it did not
okay you then say see a dermatologist
yeah then i go
then
and then what was the life
then you go because i want you to live
forever yeah yeah
yeah all right it wasn't like see i
wasn't like commanding you all right so
they're retired i wasn't so that that
could have been to me that's the limit
so i'm like okay that could have been
right so i go like a normal human being
okay yeah right so far this is a
accurate it should end there
it should have ended there right but it
but gilbert it did not there was more
yeah so abe told me he didn't want to
scare you but he thinks it looks
cancerous okay then i go are you [ __ ]
serious question mark no i'm
scared
right but it didn't end there right you
sent me this
i sent you a screenshot of a screenshot
of what a b said to me
he said to me he said by the way ethan i
didn't want to scare bobby but that 100
percent looks cancerous okay good that's
what he told me so we get the facts out
but but so so i'm like yo i really want
to make sure he's now now
i'm literally from that moment on until
i went to the doctor
it's what was in my thoughts but do you
know what let me just the good news is
you're going to live
so let me just say why i'm angry
okay
from that moment on until the doctor's
appointment and i listen people are
probably listening going
siding with ethan that's fine
like ethan's a good friend because i'm
going to tell you something
when i went
i drove all the way to beverly hills
where your guy is right yeah i don't
want to say his name there are
dermatologists in the valley just fyi
because bob i i took because i was
watching you talk about it you're like i
drove three hours to bed yeah yeah and i
was like first of all it doesn't take
three hours it was a trafficking day
friday it was a friday i know it didn't
take traffic not three hours all right
so but then i go well it goes bobby
there's a there's a you live in a very
affluent part of town you don't have to
go to beverly hills for some posh
dermatologist to look at your moisture
well she's partly the brilliant name for
that wait that's what they'll throw me
under the bus that's her recommendation
that's her dermatologist and i trust her
don't remember
that's okay all right that's all i'm
saying okay but don't blame me for the
far drive because you chose
yeah that's a good point okay not my
fault you took a damn road trip that's
not the point but anyway i go all right
i go there i park where i paid pay valet
and uh went up there waited 30 minutes i
did they don't read they didn't read
they didn't validate you no well
so anyway i go i go and he goes what's
the problem
i go i have cancer on my neck
i'm dying i have cancer on my neck okay
and he goes let me look and he looks at
my neck and he goes yeah there's i don't
know what do you mean what are you even
referring to
that's an exaggeration that's an
exaggeration can i ask you a question at
this point
i said you weren't there i know but like
i'm sure he knows what you're referring
to because that mole was very giant
[ __ ] crazy listen
to texas
like the shape is not sanity it's pure
insanity what you're saying i go to the
mall he goes oh it's a mole
and i go cancer
and he goes no it's just a mole
are you sure you guys
i'm 90 i go he goes i'm 90.99999
90 only nine no i'm 99 points because
you said i'm 99.999999
he did 15 or 16 nine but he's saying
there's percent
it's not
he goes so
he goes thanks for the visit and i go um
no remove it
because why
and i go
bring it to the labs get it checked out
he's like i i it's not cancer dude it's
a mole
i go i don't care i drove all the way
over here you're doing something okay so
he removes it and now it's been itchy as
[ __ ] i lost a friend you want to see it
kind of i do actually yeah
so that's interesting did he
do like a little surgery there yeah he
surgery he took us he was just like i
don't need to do it it's just going to
grow it might grow back i go no
yeah sometimes they do they sometimes
they do
i'm just saying that i want to get a
close look at the no you're not even
getting i just turned your turn yeah
so yeah you got some redness there yeah
yeah so i'm just gonna say right it was
just a re i don't know why a friend
would make another friend do such
inconvenience activities
it was inconvenient
it was a lot of head space wouldn't have
been inconvenient if he was right dude
if i saved your life how [ __ ] epic
would that be but that's why you want to
be the hero yes yes and this whole thing
is about you being a hero yes but you're
not you're a coward like i am
yeah yeah you're a coward like i am your
trickster but i couldn't it wasn't
cancer admit that and just apologize
i genuinely thought you should get it
checked out okay
but but so you did about so you did a
biopsy gilbert who's in the wrong
obviously ethan
right but i honestly look at me right
now gilbert
are you do you think no
gilbert look at this no you're looking
at him like in a comedy way dude and all
i'm saying and i want you to be real all
right i'm sorry sweetie maybe i'm being
a child about that right but let me no i
just want to hear my here's my real
point right and just be real about it
and maybe you could sway me on his side
and then we could just move on and talk
about
other things think about any other
friends in the industry
okay he had to go on a limb and say this
is going to be so embarrassing if i'm
wrong but i'm worried about bobby yeah
that could be so but then bravery but so
yes point to that bravery bobby
but the idea but i will say saying
all the extra stuff like hey my friend's
doctor
he's he's went to med school
and he said it's 100 percent i want to
enjoy that
i want to interject and say
you um employed the only strategy that
could have worked that was why i did it
because i knew
and you said it yourself when i watched
you talking about earlier you said it's
unbelievable no listen to what i'm
saying buddy it's unbelievable what you
just did babe no
i was gonna make that point he
you don't know him he's a [ __ ] mental
trickster man you know what bobby you
guys are she's [ __ ] here and she
doesn't owe you anything and now she can
finally speak the truth to you
it's time to listen all right
[Music]
z-o-c-d-o-c zoc dot guide this is an
amazing app i'm telling you right for
instance when i didn't have a family
doctor and stuff i didn't know where to
go so i just asked my neighbor